welcome to exploring computing
today's video is bits bytes and binary
part two or one plus one equals one
zero so in the last lecture we took a
look at binary numbers
and why computers use the binary number
system
in this lecture we're going to take a
closer look at how binary numbers
actually work
now i do want to start off by saying we
are going to be taking a look at a bit
of math here in this particular video
and i don't want people to think that
this is what the bulk of this class is
going to look like
this is largely the only video in which
we're going to be looking at math but i
do think that
having a sense of how these binary
numbers really work and
getting a sense for when you see a
binary number what it actually
might represent is going to be pretty
useful as things go on
we're going to see that the binary
number system pervades computers
and that there are many many places
where the fact that the underlying
representation
of data in the computer that uses these
binary numbers
is going to leak out into the real world
let's go ahead and take a look at this
so let's start off by learning how to
count now i know that seems like an odd
place to start off
a lecture at stanford university but
bear with me
we're going to review how to count
decimal and this will turn out to be
useful when we're trying to understand
how counting
in binary works so i'm going to start
off with a 0 and i'm going to add 1 to
it and of course that's going to give us
1.
we're going to add 1 to 1 and that will
give us two we'll add two to one and
that'll give us three
and so on and then we'll continue on
we'll get to eight
we'll add one to eight that'll give us
nine we'll add one to nine
and that's where things get a little bit
dicey because remember we're working
with the decimal
number system there are only ten digits
starting with zero going up to nine
and so what happens when we try and add
one to nine is there's no eleventh digit
so what happens is
we carry the one and we reset our ones
to zero and we end up with one
zero or which is of course ten now we
can continue on so
ten plus one is eleven eleven plus one
is twelve and so on
now when we get to nineteen plus one
well
this is similar to what happened with a
nine plus one we know that we can't go
to
one some digit greater than nine because
there are only ten digits zero through
nine
and so again we carry the one over and
we end up with 20.
this will continue on we get 98 plus one
equals 99
we get 99 plus one and again we have
this situation where
neither the tens digits nor the ones
digit can go any higher
we only have ten digits so we carry over
from
the ones to the tens and from the tens
to the next digit over which will be the
hundreds
and so we end up with a hundred okay
fair enough
let's take a look at how this works in
binary now
so in binary we're going to start off
with zero plus one again just as we did
in decimal
zero plus one in binary is equal to one
just as zero plus one
and decimal is equal to one but as soon
as we get to the next step
we run into a problem what does one plus
one equal in
binary well this is analogous to the
situation we got to before when we tried
to add
1 to 9 in the decimal number system the
decimal number system we had those 10
individual digits in the binary number
system we only have two digits 0
and 1. so when we add 1 to 1 there is no
third digit there's only 0 and 1 and so
we need to go ahead and carry the 1 over
so this will actually give us 1
0. we can go ahead and add
1 to 1 0 which will give us 1 1 when we
try and add
1 to 1 1 this is similar to the
situation where we tried to add 1 to 99
we need to carry the 1 over and so we're
going to get 1 0
0. we can keep on going with this so
1 0 0 plus 1 equals 101 we can keep
going
and continue on and so what i've written
up here is
the first eight numbers of the binary
number system are actually the first
nine of you consider zero is the first
number in the binary number system so 0
1 1 0 1 1 1 0 0 101
1 1 0 1 1 1 and finally 1 0 0
0. so here are the first 16 numbers in
the binary number system and you can see
that they are the dust
the equivalent of the decimal numbers 0
through 15. you'll also notice that i've
got these little subscripts next to each
of the numbers
so these subscripts are sometimes used
to disambiguate when it's not clear what
particular number system
a number is using so in this
example here i've got the number 6 on
the left but i want to emphasize that
it's a decimal number so that 10
in subscript after the 6 represents that
that
6 on the left side here is base 10
and the 2 on the that's a subscript on
the right
represents that that number on the right
is base 2.
now without it without that subscript 10
and without that scope subscript 2 you
would probably guess that the number on
the left is base 10 because
it's clearly not binary it's got it's
got a digit there 6 which does not exist
in the binary number system although
there are some other number systems like
the base 8 number system which
occasionally gets used in computer
science
and then there's a base 16 number system
called hexadecimal which does get used
quite a bit in computer science
we'll look at that in another lecture
and so that six on the left could be
either one of those number systems and
so putting that 10 down there at the
bottom emphasizes that this is in fact
a decimal number and on the right 1 1 0
this could represent 110
in base 10 and so that little subscript
there too
tells us that no this is not 110 this is
actually 1
1 0. which does kind of bring us to the
next
question which is how are we working out
the equivalencies of these
different numbers so let's take a very
short look at this
and i'm not going to require you guys to
be able to do the conversion from
binary to decimal you know at any point
in the quarter
and this is the point where i would
normally say we're not going to make you
do it on an exam but
hey because we're under quarantine there
are no exams so
uh go coronavirus i guess but i do want
you to
to have a sense of how it works so again
we're going to start with a decimal
number because this is a system we're
used to and by reminding ourselves
of how the system actually works will
help us
when we try and convert it to binary so
here i've got the number
1891. now if you think about
what does 1891 actually represent
we've got four different digits here the
one on the far right
represents 10 to the zeroth power which
is
our ones the num the second number over
the 9
represents our 2 to the first power or
our tens
the eight represents 10 to the second
power or hundreds
and the fourth number over represents
our third powers
are 10 to the third which is a thousand
so if i'm looking at 1891
i know i have 1 10 to the 0th power i
have
9 10 to the first powers 8 10 to the
second powers
and 1 10 to the third power so i have 1
plus 90 plus 800 plus a thousand which
gives us 1891.
let's go ahead and take a look at how
this works with binary numbers
so here i've got the binary number 1 1 0
1. what is the decimal equivalent of
this well
on the far right in the zeroth place
i have my two to the zeros so these
this these are one because two to the
zero power is
one the next place over represents my
two to the first powers so those
represent our
twos next to that to the left i have our
two to the second powers which represent
fours
and then one step over from that i have
our two to the third powers which are
eights
in this particular case i have one two
to the zero power
i have no two to the first powers
i have 1 2 to the second power
and i have 1 2 to the third power so i
have
1 plus 0 plus 4 plus 8
which means that this is the equivalent
of a decimal 13.
so one thing that's going to be
important for us when we're representing
information
is how many different combinations
can we store in a given number of bits
so
let's start off with one bit what can we
represent in a single bit
well we can either represent a zero or a
one
what is that actually good for the most
common thing that we can use
a zero or a one to represent is actually
whether something is true or false
so are we going to be able to come back
to stanford
for summer session well if that bit is
stirring a 1
then the answer is yes and if that bit
of storing is 0 then the answer is no
how many different combinations can we
store in two bits
well here are the different combinations
two bits and you can see that there are
four possible combinations
how about the combinations in three bits
here are the different combinations in
three bits
and then finally here are the
combinations in four bits
so the way to think of these is you can
either think of them as
oh those are binary numbers and we saw
how to convert those to decimal a minute
ago
so you know we have these 16 possible
combinations
these could represent the decimal
numbers between 0
and 15 but they might be used to
represent something else so for example
i could
i could use these 16 combinations to
represent the ten provinces in canada so
if we were a school in canada
and we wanted to know which province
somebody lived in
i could have zero zero zero zero for
example represent
prince edward island and zero zero zero
one
nova scotia 0010 representing new
brunswick and so on
could we represent information about u.s
states and our four bids no
we can't there's 50 different states and
we can only store
up to 16 different combinations in our
four bits so
well our canadian provinces fit into
four bit and in fact we could
comfortably add in the three
canadian territories as well we simply
do not have enough space in four bits to
store the us
states and in fact if we had five bits
we still couldn't store it we're going
to see that we actually need
six bits to store all the states the
union
so we've seen that in one bit we can
represent two combinations and two bits
we can represent
four three eight four sixteen
and it turns out there's a simple
formula here if we have n
bits we can represent two to the n
combinations and so here you can see the
common number of combinations we can
have for one two three
four five six seven eight nine and ten
bits
now when you're looking at these
different combinations keep in mind that
these individual bits could represent
numbers they can represent positive and
negative numbers
they can represent different things like
our canadian provinces
we could use a certain sequence of bits
to represent
dorms at stanford and so one of the
things that the programmer is going to
have to decide to do
is what do they want to do with the
individual bits when we're designing a
program
we're going to need to decide how many
bits to set aside for what particular
quantities
and how we're going to represent things
with bits and bytes and that's something
that we're going to be exploring more
later this lecture and throughout
throughout the rest of this week now
another thing that you might notice is
if we're looking at these numbers here
two four eight sixteen thirty two sixty
four hundred twenty eight two fifty six
five hundred twelve
these may look a little bit familiar to
you if you've gone shopping for a new
say iphone recently how much memory do
you buy in an iphone can you buy a
hundred megabytes can you buy 250
megabytes
no you buy 128 or 256 or 512
why because those are powers of two and
because internally the computer
uses the binary number system now
we've only solved half the mystery
though now we understand why
we buy iphones with 64 128 or 256
but why do we buy them in megabytes
or gigabytes instead of millions
and billions well it turns out that
millions
billions thousands these are all powers
of 10
and again internally we're using the
binary number system
not the decimal number system and so
kilobytes megabytes gigabytes and
terabytes are the base two equivalent
and you can see from this table here
that two to the tenth
is about a thousand but it's actually a
little bit bigger
and two to the 20th which is a megabyte
is
about a million but it's actually a
little bit bigger and the same thing for
gigabytes and terabytes
so the idea here is we're going to give
you roughly
the same amount as a billion or a
million or
a thousand but we want to do it in a
power of two
and you can see here some higher order
numbers that you might run into
someday peta exa zeta and yoda
i should mention that there is some
disagreement between
the electoral engineers and the computer
scientists on whether or not we should
be using powers of two so
there are places where when we're
working with electrical engineers they
will use
kila mega or giga and they'll actually
be real referring to
thousands millions and billions in base
10. and so the most common place you
might run into this is when you're
talking about communication speeds
those are generally actually given in
powers of 10.
all right in the next lecture we're
going to take a look at what happens
when things go wrong with our binary
numbers